very Where's Waldo for Tommy Hilfiger
spring 2019 cheek no company disgraced
I'll be done tonight no your life is
different now
over the weekend I was under the weather
and somehow that led to me watching the
entire last season of Bad Girls Club in
one day
I chose Club is a reality show where a
bunch of bad girls live in a house
together shenanigans ensue
[Applause]
it was fun and watching this I thought
YouTube's not doing as well as Ebisu I
love that girl maybe I need to seek out
other employment opportunities so here's
my official audition tape for season 18
of Bad Girls Club that's a little sore
from all of the dick I've been deep
throating I just have seasonal head call
hi my name is grace Helbig and this is
my official auditioning tape for Bad
Girls Club season 18 on to be determined
network as you can probably already tell
I'm a very bad girl
east coast I have a lot of qualities
that would make me a suitable cast
member of season 18 of the bad girls
club
for instance you better call an attorney
to sue me because I flaunt what I got I
don't take [ __ ] I'm very constantly
right not on this new pumpkin series and
bran cereal at sprouts delicious but I
am like I should as like Melania Trump
yeah I'm not here to make friends I'm
pretty awful at maintaining the current
relationships I have in my daily life
[Music]
watch out I like to pop off I have a
sore throat
out out I'm messy
take care of [ __ ] get some treats
I'm always ready to go can you go out
with Hardy I don't have time for house
no today I gots daddy the shoes my dad
left me a voice mail the other day and I
haven't called him back he cares about
my general well-being he's a good man
I'm a bad daughter there you go there's
all the reasons I would make a
successful cast member a bad girls club
season 18 so you know what to do you
better hire me don't make me come for
you I have trouble where guys men
I don't know
look I'm a bad girl and I love clubs I
was in Latin club all through high
school
semper visa booby always wear underwear
that's what that means ooh nasty see
thank you for what we party thank you
for the lovely party thank you for the
lovely party